[Music]
so
[Music]
safety's off
her feet are planted
her face is poised will this be the
moment of her death
nobody knows
oh my gosh
that's the best thing i've ever seen
did i hit it
you didn't hit it he destroyed it fire
it up
i've always wanted to do this
yes
uh
we should probably get out of here
you're an adult
yeah
and liable
you know what this means right
your grandfather was a ghostbuster
[Music]
can you stop breathing in my ear no
you guys this is kind of stupid are you
sure you didn't see like a raccoon or
like
a pasta
is that
free floating metal muncher
definitely class five okay uh what do we
do
what
we get a photo first
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
go go
[Music]
blue velvet
[Music]
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing here in somerville
anyway
honestly
my mom won't say it but we're broke
we just got evicted and the only thing
that's left in our name is this creepy
old farmhouse our grandfather left us in
the middle of nowhere
no offense
i'm not offended
this place is dumb
but why do you live here
i'm fourth generation dump
[Music]
get out
what is that
hi
hello again
you brought them home
it's a service i provide
art well i'm i'm also an escort
okay
look the truth is i've always kind of
wondered what lurked inside this hunt
box
right well the only thing lurking inside
here is my slowly dying soul
is that what that smell is
well it's not dinner so
um
would you sure
like yeah
i don't have any food it's fine tour
great great
you're a great mom
i don't know i'm fine with trevor
but with phoebe
she really keeps me on the outside
that's normal she's an awkward
nerdy kid
[Music]
maybe a new home can be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish he'd get into some trouble
there's still time
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke and our
grandfather left us this creepy old
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on you're
saying he left us nothing
well i wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here
somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason
are you troubled by strange noises in
the middle of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
have you or any of your family ever seen
a spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
you guys hear that
something's coming
all city
it's like the walking dead
we're closed
i'm ivan reitman director of
ghostbusters and ghostbusters 2 better
known as dad
and i'm his son jason reitman director
of ghostbusters afterlife
the ghostbusters 84 set is the first set
i can remember as a kid it was just
simply magical he was there with his mom
my wife and uh
they in fact they actually used it in
this
in one moment in the film when he got
cut out of the original ghostbusters
that's what he's getting at
they got scared after the first take
jason wouldn't do a second take
ghostbusters afterlife is a movie about
a family that's being made by a family
and it is much about the passing of
torch metaphorically and the passing of
a proton pack it was very emotional to
see that
uh story living again after so many
years
through my son
i grew up as a fan i had a flight suit i
had the t-shirt i had the hat now at
this age
i find myself trying to understand who
my father is and who he was when he made
this film you know i am now the age that
my father was when he made the original
ghostbusters movie and i'm trying to
understand him in the same way that
phoebe and callie are trying to
understand where they came from
while making the movie my father's
presence was felt most like this
inches away
watching the monitor
imagine
yourself in your workplace and your
parents are sitting right next to you
watching you take every phone call
watching you present any idea
chiming in
often
[Music]
it was probably more fun for me than for
jason
there was a moment when we were shooting
with three cameras a scene with five or
six actors
and i found myself on set sitting next
to one of the cameras watching one actor
in particular who i wanted a performance
from
and after the take was done i ran back
to monitor to review the other cameras
and my father looked at me and just said
you got it
i went okay and i nodded and we moved on
which is not an experience that could
have ever happened or probably will ever
happen on any other movie jason had a
remarkable responsibility having to deal
with his father on the set and also the
history and iconography of 35 years of
audiences all over the world getting to
know this movie and he took it on which
i thought was a great thing to do my
father and i are extraordinarily close
it was a joyful experience just to be
there it was the great bonding
experience of my life with the director
that i admire most my father
phone's probably mine dad i'm in the
like i i'm trying
to do
the ep
back to one guys
[Music]
[Music]
you